the Republican party will be in good
standing to oppose late-term abortion
like most of the Civilized world
quick covering for these guys what no no
no your media you keep covering for
these guys they introduce legislation
that allowed abortion On Demand with
taxpayer-funded uh well you paying for
it the taxpayer up to the bone of birth
that was their position in Washington
That's the Law they want to pass and
nobody in your business will talk about
it the temper tantrum by Lindsey Graham
accusing down a bash of covering for
them just because she inserted one
little measly fact into the discussion
that is a result of the propaganda
bubble that the Republican party is so
used to